I'm inspired every time I get on the
subway everyone is really tuned in
that's the thing about New York is it's
very aware of things that are going on
whether it's clothing or food or design
architecture New York is a fast changing
place and you know in the fashion
business anyway it's where things things
started a lot of times we grew up here
in the city and my parents in the 70s I
mean they were full on 57th Street
Studio 54 fashion idea
my dad's a jewelry designer and so he
used to make a lot of jewelry for Vegas
celebrities Ray Charles and Sammy Davis
Liberace as well was a bit tailor but
they were like big chunky you know Multi
finger rings after I graduated they
asked me to manage their store and I
don't remember this one swatch watches
it was like a mania that was going on my
mother and said why don't you go and buy
these watches and then bring them back
and we'll sell them and I saved up money
from that business to open my first
store which was in 1994 I feel like you
don't really reinvent the wheel as much
as put your own personal stamp on it and
that's always been what I wanted to wear
growing up I didn't always have
self-confidence but when it came to
doing something that I felt passionate
about here you could see the the placket
twists right here and then the stitch
it's got like a stitched down collar
which is kind of interesting and then on
the sides it has the seam on the outside
whereas normally it would be finished
clean like that that was the first
signature shirt and that came about
because I asked the factory to make the
shirt with the seams on the outside
because I thought that would be a cool
detail so they thought I wanted the
whole thing reversed and usually I like
to wear things when we first make them
and
everyone was like wow that's a great
shirt you know our seamless sweater it's
one of our best sweaters that we do but
it's just the silhouette it's like oh if
you know then you know but if you don't
know you would have no idea normally
there would be a seam here it has to be
woven on a circular knitting machine as
opposed to someone cutting it and sewing
it super subtle this is our number one
right now it's a really nice brushed
blue Mullane the mission if we had it
written on a wall would be timeless
effortless understated clothing if we
can create something that is signature
without it having our name all over it
then we've done something good I was
thinking of ways to sort of take a polo
and make it more signature and so we
played around with a vintage one that I
hadn't I just cut it not a designer you
know I don't know how to dray for a
sketch I like those like this but I know
what I like what I don't like does this
feel on Brandon was not going during
this I think it's from doing it for as
long as we're doing it it's that paper
paper sound I like it in the beginning
it was more like this is a private label
it wasn't until other stores wanted to
carry it that was sort of strange to me
because I was like really I kind of
questioned whether it was possible not
having gone to fashion school not having
you know been trained or worked for
anyone else it was just can I do this
you know and it was great to see that I
could
I like the stores to be neighborhood
stores that's always been important to
me
Atlanta Kemeny just feels like the
artery it's kind of like the it's like
Main Street in Brooklyn good are you
doing but yet it still feels like a
little neighborhood so that's what's
nice about it I'm very active some
designers design and then they hand it
off and then thinking about having a
more consistent scale yeah that's good
what I enjoy is not just the designing
part but it's the design part putting it
in the stores selling it to other stores
seeing it sell well and doing it again
we have 22 stores and this is the newest
store which is Newport Beach I like
seeing things for up you make something
and then people buy it and they love it
or you go out and you see them wearing
it that's the fun for me it's the whole
process
getting off the train and walking home
and then getting home and seeing my kids
it's the best way to unwind my family is
the de-stress or when I'm working when
I'm in the office oh it's always the
future so it's like how can we make this
better what are we gonna do next we're
good and then with the kids it's like
look at this fire truck you know look at
this dance you've got to be there you've
got to be present and if you're not
they'll call you on earth and they'll be
like what look at me tell me what